Привет! В прошлом уроке мы получили два файла: быстрый ресерч через агенты и результат глубокого
исследования через Deep Research. У нас есть сырые данные по конкурентам — это фичи, цены, UX,
плюсы и минусы, рыночная статистика. Полезно, но в таком виде это рабочие заметки. Показать клиенту
или руководителю такое нельзя. Сейчас превратим это в документ, с которым можно работать — свод по
каждому конкуренту. Таблица фич, анализ UX паттернов и выводы для нашего продукта. Помним,
что мы работаем в одной среде, поэтому агент уже видит и бриф, и оба файла с ресерчем. Контекст
объяснять заново, конечно, не нужно. Для этого урока я подготовил ещё одну директиву,
которая запустит весь процесс. В нём четыре шага — это свод, таблица фич, UX паттерны и финальный
документ. Каждый шаг — это отдельный файл. Вот эта директива, она у меня уже лежит здесь. В чём
она заключается? Агент читает бриф об ресерче и дальше работает сам, раскладывает конкурентов в свод,
собирает таблицу фич, анализирует UX паттерны и в конце собирает всё в один документ summary. Я уже
запустил эту директиву, просто сюда перетянул, даже ничего ему не писал, он сам понял, что ему
делать. Ну, потому что в этом файлике всё, конечно, описано. Итак, только обрати внимание на одну мелочь:
BriefMD — у нас уже установлено, что будет такое название в предыдущей директиве, поэтому тут всё
совпадёт. BriefMD будет называться также, Competitive Analyze также будет называться. Вот Deep Research Results — мы
делали это глубокое исследование в другом сервисе, сюда закидывали этот MD-файл, соответственно, тебе
нужно его назвать точно также. Отсюда копируем название и для своего вот этого глубокого исследования
его переименовываем. Правой кнопкой мыши — Rename, чтобы агент точно понял, что нужно взаимодействовать
с конкретно этим файлом. Все четыре файла сейчас у нас готовы, которые предусматривает наша директива.
Давай пойдём по каждому из них, посмотрим, как они выглядят. Через превью откроем, чтобы удобнее с этим
ознакомливаться. Итак, тут у нас свод по каждому конкуренту. Сильные стороны и слабые стороны — это
про сам продукт и opportunities, и возможности и угрозы — это что его продукт значит для нас. Обратите
внимание, что агент оценивает конкурентов через призму именно нашего продукта, потому что он прочитал
бриф. Давайте посмотрим, на что точно стоит обращать внимание. В weakness или слабости ищите повторяющиеся
паттерны. Если у нескольких конкурентов одна и та же слабость, это значит, что это системная
проблема рынка. Значит, пользователи живут с ней уже давно. Если вы её закроете — это сильный аргумент.
Тридц или угрозах — смотрите на риски развития. Агент здесь формулирует эти угрозы таким образом,
что если конкурент X добавит какую-то фичу, они закроют нашу нишу. Конкурентный анализ не только
про текущее состояние, но и про то, куда рынок вообще движется. Если агент что-то упустил или ошибся — поправьте.
Вы наверняка самостоятельно ещё будете ознакомливаться с документами, с глубоким анализом и так далее.
Может быть, что-то самостоятельно подсветите. У вас всегда есть возможность дополнить этот список.
Просто здесь, в MD-файле, дописав какие-нибудь там новые угрозы, например, или сильные стороны.
Но обрати внимание, что тогда у тебя вот эта новая угроза не синхронизируется с итоговым файлом и
остальными смежными по именно конкурентному анализу. Поэтому для внесения таких изменений лучше ему сюда и писать,
что добавь вот эту угрозу и он все остальные файлики тоже пересмотрит.
Давайте посмотрим таблицу фич. Строки — это конкретные фичи, колонки — это наши конкуренты и мы.
Зелёным отмечено то, что у них есть, желтым — то, что есть частично, и красным — то, чего у них нет.
Ну, я думаю, это и так понятно.
Здесь все фичи также у нас сгруппированы.
Управление ВПС — вот некоторые перечисления фичей.
Биллинг и платежи — опять же, какое-то число фичей.
Все, опять же, исходя из нашего брифа, из нашей направленности, мы сравниваем именно те фичи, которые актуальны для нашего конкретно продукта.
Главное, что, наверное, здесь нужно найти — это строку, где у конкурентов красные галочки, а у вас зелёная.
Это ваш дифференциатор.
Это та фича, которую хотят пользователи, но которую никто не даёт.
Если такая строка есть, у вас сильная позиция.
Если же такой строки нет, это тоже результат.
Значит, дифференциация ваша может быть не в фичах, а в чём-то другом.
UX, цена, интеграция, аудитория.
Помимо фичей есть ещё много областей продукта.
Это тоже полезно сдать на старт.
И также обратите внимание ещё на строки, где у всех стоят галочки.
Это минимум, без которого продукт не воспримут всерьёз.
Если у вас в плане стоит крест напротив такой строки, это уже может стать проблемой.
Агент также отдельно выписывает фичи, которые есть у нас в плане, но нет ни у одного конкурента.
Проверьте этот список.
Иногда агент вытаскивает из брифа вещи, о которых вы забыли.
Итак, открываем следующий файлик.
Это стандарт рынка.
Тут у нас три раздела.
Рыночный стандарт, точки расхождения и рекомендации.
Давайте по каждому пройдёмся.
Первый. Рыночный стандарт — это те паттерны, которые есть у всех.
Навигация, анбординг, основные экраны.
Пользователь ожидает их по умолчанию.
Поэтому мы не сделать их не можем.
Если же вы решили что-то делать иначе, что-то в привычных паттернах пользователя менять, то нужна веская причина.
Но вообще это прям такая база-база.
Рыночный стандарт — это гравитация.
Можно с ней спорить, но нужно понимать, что вы делаете.
Дальше у нас точки расхождения.
Это уже поинтереснее.
Это задачи, которые конкуренты решают по-разному.
Здесь вы выбираете подход или придумываете свой.
Агент описывает, кто и как это делает, в чём плюсы и минусы их подходов.
И вы уже принимаете решение, каким образом это интегрировать в свой продукт.
Ну и если определиться сложно, у нас есть третий пункт — это рекомендации.
Тут агент предлагает, какие паттерны взять и почему.
Это не истинно последние станции.
Это скорее стартовая точка.
Поэтому прочитайте, подумайте, скорректируйте, если с чем-то не согласны.
И также здесь есть конкретно для нашего продукта, что точно не стоит брать.
Например, в Таймвебе пошаговый визард для создания сервера.
Это делает это создание долгим.
И, в принципе, это не нужно при одном-трёх серверах.
У нас по итогам брифа не какие-то огромные компании, у которых будет по 500 серверов.
Это частные пользователи.
Соответственно, у них не будет много серверов и какая-то мега-настройка им не нужна.
Соответственно, одна страница на создание этого сервака — это намного удобнее, проще и не будет способствовать оттоку пользователей.
Итак, переходим к самому последнему нашему файлу.
Это итоговый документ.
Он нас максимально кратко, сжато вводит, какая сейчас вообще ситуация на рынке и в чем наше преимущество.
Вот, например, у нас изначально в брифе было выбрано, что мы работаем в России.
Вот, например, он нам риск определил, что прием крипты за услуги в РФ запрещен.
Но иностранное юрлицо в ОАЭ или Гонконге позволяет легально работать как международный провайдер.
Соответственно, нам нужно будет базироваться там.
Также UX-стандарты определены конкурентом Digital Ocean.
Опять же, что у нас должно быть?
Телеграм-уведомления, SSH-терминал — все это должно у нас работать.
Также валюта, в которой мы крипту должны принимать, рост рынка, описание ниши и так далее.
Дальше у нас таблица фич.
Это краткий свод, UX-рекомендации и выводы.
Все в одном файле.
Все ссылается на данные из предыдущих шагов.
Дальше у нас таблица фич, краткий свод, UX-рекомендации и сами выводы.
Все в одном файле.
Все ссылается на данные из предыдущих шагов, из предыдущих файлов.
Этот документ остается в проекте.
Когда мы дойдем до персон, до PRD, агент будет его использовать.
Он знает рынок, знает конкурентов, знает нашу позицию.
Итак, у вас есть файлы ресерча из прошлого урока.
Теперь мы запускаем директиву конкурентного анализа из материалов к уроку.
Агент сделает все за 4 шага.
Когда результат будет готов, прочитайте summary и таблицу фич.
Есть ли строка, где вы отличаетесь от всех.
И что, например, агент вынес в факторе риска.
Формат сдачи – это скрин финального документа.
Ваш короткий вывод, в чем ваш главный дифференциатор и какой главный риск.
Все это у себя сохраняем, оставляем и переходим к следующему уроку.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
Встретимся на следующем уроке.